valéry giscard d'estaing à salon de
provence pour une défense aérienne plus
moderne et plus mobiles les paradoxes de
l'aéronautique française
un bon point la vente d hélicoptères une
ombre la fusée spatiale européenne
georges marchais aux socialistes
négocions sur les propositions de la
cfdt
les explications de laurence graff le
dossier d'antenne 2 sur les économies
européennes ce soir l'allemagne
même monsieur bonsoir cette voix qui
vous a annoncé les types vous a
peut-être un petit peu surprise elle
n'est pas vraiment dans le ton habituel
du journal mais si vous écoutez la radio
depuis longtemps vous l'avez forcément
reconnu c'est celle d'un speaker du
temps où les speakers avait de belles
voix de basse et c'est cette voie que
vous entendez depuis hier soir après ce
journal pour annoncer la campagne
électorale officielle alors jacques le
rat il faut maintenant qu'on vous voit
pas ce qu'on vous en regard de la loi
il faut dire que le speaker c'est une
race qui est un peu en voie de
disparition
oui c'est une voie en race une voix une
rarissime de race en voie de disparition
peut-être à cause des journalistes cause
aussi des ce qu'on appelle les les
meneurs de jeu les animateurs c'est à
dire que c'est une profession qui il y a
trente ans était quand même assez bien
considérer au journal parlé car je suis
rentré la radio de la nation française
1944 qui après devenue la radio
française puis la radiodiffusion
télévision française puis lauwe rtf et
maintenant et maintenant radio france
est assez des peuples a jusqu'en 1960 et
journaliste débat vraiment des
journalistes mais si vous l'aidez des
rédacteurs et ses rédacteurs sont
devenus après deux de grands
journalistes et scellant ainsi annoncé
l'information et il ya place pour les
suisses l'ont fait depuis soixante
toutes les informations à l'époque est
élu par les speakers tous les journaux
parlés et est depuis 1960 ce sont 60 61
ce sont les journalistes qui
et aujourd'hui sont aperçus série b le
voit aussi eh bien eh bien les speakers
ne se sont pas si vous voulez recyclé ma
faille et du travail pour tout le monde
personnellement je je participe à la vie
de france culture à la ville de loin
tant du doigt la belle voix à la vie de
france musique aussi pour annoncer des
des concerts jazz mende
il reste sur une cinquantaine de speaker
en 1945 il en reste quatre dont trois
femmes et un homme et le l'homme c'est
moi eh bien ma balle en reprenait sa
tête
rendez vous donc à la fin de ce journal
je serai en compagnie de georges
marchais de deux représentants du rpr et
d'un supporters du front
autogestionnaire valéry giscard
d'estaing à salon de provence ce matin
après une parenthèse de trois jours dans
le fort de brégançon chef de l'état a
visité l'école de l'air de salon de
provence et a ainsi achevé sa tournée
d'inspection des écoles militaires il
était déjà allé à saint cyr coëtquidan
et à l'école navale de brest et le
programme public a profité de l'occasion
pour justifier le choix du futur avion
de chasse de l'armée de l'air française
le mirage 2000 et pour annoncer une très
rapide progression de la force de
dissuasion
il faut savoir je suis est indiqué
récemment pour le gouvernement que les
moyens de dissuasion de la france en
1990 seront à peu près 3 froid les
moyens actuels c'est la place principale
de la déclaration du président la
république à salon-de-provence arrivée
du fort de brégançon
valéry giscard d'estaing passé en revue
les 400 élèves visiter les salles
d'étude et les logements des
pensionnaires avant de s'adresser aux
officiers et à ses élèves de l'école de
l'air pour leur expliquer comment
avaient été prises
les grandes décisions engageant l'avenir
de l'armée de l'air dans le domaine de
la défense aérienne et celui de la
dissuasion
depuis que notre politique de défense
est fondé d'abord sur la dissuasion
l'émission général des armées et
notamment celle de l'armée de l'air sont
clairement définis mais l'évolution des
menaces et des techniques impose une
adaptation constante des modalités de
l'exécution de ses missions et aussi des
moyens nécessaires pour les remplir
s'agissant de la dissuasion
vous savez que l'armée de l'air met en
oeuvre deux de ses composantes
sur un total de trois composantes les
mirage iv jusqu'à l'horizon 85 ou
peut-être des années immédiatement
suivante et les missiles stratégiques du
plateau d'albion jusqu'à l'horizon 1995
2000 des études sont menées actuellement
pour définir les moyens les plus aptes à
compléter à ces dates respectives ce que
continuera à mettre en oeuvre la force
océanique stratégique puisque la
composante sous-marine de notre force de
dissuasion reste elle assuré de son
avenir
pour l'ensemble de cette période ces
études qui sont actuellement entreprises
par l'état major fera apparaître qu'il
pourra s'agir soit d'une nouvelle
génération de missiles fixe ou semi
mobiles soit de missiles aérodynamique
qui d'ailleurs dans leur version
aéroportée conserverait des avantages
la composante piloter ces études qui
viennent d'être entreprises seront
conduites avec la plus grande minutie
d'une part pour tenir compte de
l'ensemble des données internationales
et aussi pour veiller au bon emploi des
ressources de la nation avant cette
déclaration sur l'avenir des moyens de
dispersion de la france le président de
la république avait assisté à cette
présentation en vol du cap 20 avions
d'entraînement de l'alphajet et de la
patrouille de france
il a indiqué à salon de provence que le
mirage 2000 se recommandait à plus de
100 exemplaires pour l'armée de l'air
voici l'alphajet vous allez voir
maintenant la patrouille de france
là pas de démonstrations d'hélicoptères
pour le chef de l'état sont en provence
ce n'est peut-être pas assez
spectaculaire et c'est pourtant l'un des
secteurs de l'aviation française qui se
vend le mieux encore 200 hélicoptères
vendu ce matin au brésil par le général
mitterrand le pdg de l'aérospatiale le
général mitterrand qui peut ainsi se
consoler des récents déboires de
concorde
ces hélicoptères sont français mais ils
sont connus dans le monde entier la
preuve notre pays est au premier rang
des constructeurs d'hélicoptères en
europe et au deuxième dans le monde
après les américains avec 328
hélicoptère vendus en 77
la société nationale aérospatiale couvre
plus de 25% de son chiffre d'affaires
total les trois quarts de la production
vont d'ailleurs à l'exportation et ce
marché en pleine expansion garantie du
travail au moins pour deux ans dans ce
domaine par exemple au brésil ce marché
des hélicoptères vient de se concrétiser
et l'accord signé aujourd'hui prévoit la
construction d'une usine avec capitaux
brésiliens et français
une première tranche verra la
construction de 200 écureuil un petit
hélicoptère de cinq à six places
en fait le successeur de l'alouette 2 et
2,30 lama le seul appareil capable de
porter l'équivalent de son propre poids
c'est à dire une tonne avec des accords
de ce genre les hélicoptères perron
peut-être une partie du déficit des
avions de lafenasse comme corvette et
qu'on corps reste encore quelques
secondes dans l'espace avec cette
réunion depuis ce matin et jusqu'à
demain du conseil de lézard autrement
dit de love spatiale l'europe sociale
qui est un petit peu sur le fil du
rasoir en ce moment à tel point que
valéry giscard d'estaing et helmut
schmidt ont délibéré de son sort au
début de ce mois son sort c'est à dire
essentiellement l'avenir une fusée
ariane
la fusée ariane c'est le symbole de
l'indépendance de l'europe c'est elle
qui permettra à nos satellites de faire
ce qu'ils veulent télécommunications
étude des ressources de la terre
observations espionnage l'an prochain à
kourou en guyane française la première
ariane prendra son envol aujourd'hui
tous les essais ont été réussis tous les
moteurs ont parfaitement fonctionné en
voici un
un essai effectué à vernon dans l'eure à
la base de la société européenne
de propulsion pourtant tout le monde
n'est pas d'accord pour construire
ariane le rôle spatiale a calculé qu'il
lui fallait dès aujourd'hui lancer la
construction de six fusées pour être
prêts lorsque les clients arriveront
vers 1983 1981 83
or pour lancer ces six fusées et bien il
faut trouver dès à présent 130 millions
de francs et les pays qui financent
l'europe spatiale se lire la france
l'angleterre l'allemagne la belgique etc
doivent trouver cet argent d'ici demain
parce que si on trouve pas les 130
millions ariane coûtera plus cher
puisqu'il y aura des délais dans la
fabrication et surtout arrivera trop
tard pour les clients donc ne servira
pas aussi bien
vous voyez donc l'enjeu de ce qui se
passe en ce moment à paris à la réunion
de lézat il ya d'autres problèmes
évoqués le budget de lézat et aussi les
futurs satellites qui vous permettront
chez vous de recevoir directement la
télévision du monde entier on a fait ça
et cdi de télé puis télédiffusion
directe
en voici un d'ailleurs que vous voyez
c'est un projet franco-allemand h
sattouf et bus est-ce qu'on le fera ce
qu'on ne fera pas qui le fera à combien
quel argent va t'on m voyez tous ces
problèmes sont réglés en ce moment et
demain matin à l'europe spatiale la
politique maintenant d'abord un nouveau
porte parole à l'elysée pierre inte
succède à jean philippe lecat pierre
hunt ambassadeur de france à madagascar
ancien collaborateur de jacques chaban
delmas remplace donc à ce poste jean
philippe lecat qui lui se présente aux
élections en côte d'or jean philippe
lecat qui occupait ces fonctions auprès
du grand public
depuis ou de 76 à montbard samedi devant
les jeunes giscardiens qui ouvriront
leur rassemblement à tous les jeunes de
la majorité
une fête non-stop à l'hippodrome de
paris porte de pantin
raymond barre que l'on retrouve ce soir
sur la liste des candidats publiée par
l'udf l'union pour la démocratie
française
curieusement à 12 jours maintenant des
élections le débat est étrangement calme
une seule innovation depuis hier soir
une proposition de georges marchais à
l'occasion d'un meeting à saint maur
près de paris une proposition de
compromis entre socialistes et
communistes travailler sur un document
publié au début du mois par la cfdt
alors lancera fait qu'est ce qu'il y a
dans ce document les propositions la cgt
ne sont pas nouvelles parce que la cgt
et la cgt avaient chacune élaboré un
programme au début de l'été dernier
dans la perspective d'un gouvernement de
gauche mais la cgt a ajouté de nouvelles
précisions en février dernier alors
concrètement qu'est ce que le traitement
qu est-ce qui étaient les plus propres
niveaux si elles concernent de nombreux
domaines les géants cité simplement
quelques-uns pour les comparer avec ceux
des partis de gauche pour voir les
possibilités de compromis les
différences maintenant les entreprises
nationalisées la gestion des entreprises
et les salaires alors les
nationalisations d'abord on commence
alors les nationalisations en matière
nationalisation un des grands désaccords
entre les partis de gauche portait sur
des filiales est ce qu il fallait tout
les nationaliser simplement quelques
unes
le pc le ps avait des positions très
éloignées au départ et s'était rapproché
actuellement le pc prévoit que 729
filiale devrait être nationalisé le ps
227 et la cfdt à une proposition qui est
à mi chemin et qui prévoit que serait
nationaliser les filiales dans
lesquelles les sociétés mères auraient
66% du capital soit 400 entreprises
simplement donc les la civilisation
maintenant la gestion des entreprises
1 la jci lentement à la position des
ouvriers at il baissé
la macif étant en fait le pc le ps sont
d'accord c'est la qualité qui a une
position différente pour le pc le ps les
entreprises nationalisées devrait être
gérée à la fois par les usagers les
travailleurs et les torts par un conseil
tripartite pour la cfdt s'est simplement
les travailleurs qui devrait gérer ces
entreprises
cela constitue de l'autogestion parle
c'est une des histoires de l'autogestion
une certaine conception d'autogestion
par contre oui mais tout n'est pas sain
parce qu'au niveau de l'élection du
président des entreprises nationalisées
il y a des propositions différentes
puisque le pc souhaiterait que le
président soit élu par le conseil
d'administration avec une liberté totale
des candidatures c'est à dire que
n'importe qui peut se présenter pour le
ps le président doit être élu sur une
liste proposée par le gouvernement et la
cgt elle estime que le président doit
être élu au sein du conseil des
travailleurs
c'est à dire il doit être
obligatoirement un membre de
l'entreprise alors dernier débat la
hiérarchie des salaires qui diffère aux
soeurs dernier débat la hiérarchie des
salaires
apparemment les positions sont ils sont
assez différente puisque le pc estime
que les écarts maximum de salaire dans
une entreprise dhostel de 1,5
la cgt estime qu'ils aident un à six et
pour le ps n'est pas au parti le fixer
sur des cars doit être négocié en fait
quand on regarde d'un peu plus près le
pc et le ps estime que de toute façon ce
ne doit pas se faire immédiatement à ces
été non plus et la cfdt pense que cet
écart doit également se négocie
progressivement par branche et par
étapes
voilà reste à savoir si le ps est
d'accord pour travailler sur un tel
document avant le 19 mars
cela n'est pas évident en attendant pour
cela une réaction de françois mitterrand
en attendant gaston defferre a estimé
qu'il y allant ses propos de georges
marchais le signe d'une évolution qui va
dans le bon sens et pierre mauroy dick
de toute façon ce ne sera pas discutée
avant le 19 mars
vive économistes libéraux sont partis en
guerre contre le programme commun et
notamment contre les conséquences d'une
augmentation brutale du smic
il juge cette musique cette mesure
antisociale parce que génératrice de
chômage ils ont lancé un des fils de
caunes hommiste du programme commun un
défi que jacques attali a relevé il sera
donc ce soir
opposé à pascal salin dans notre dernier
journal c'est à dire aux alentours de
minuit un record pour la régie renault
pour la première fois l exporter plus
d'un million de véhicules sur un total
d'un million 700 mille
elle dépasse ainsi de justesse
l'ensemble peugeot citroën
incontestablement ce qui l'a aidé c'est
d'avoir suivi au plus près et techniques
de construction de voitures
la chaîne classique et doucement en
train de disparaître regardez cet
exemple assez étonnant d'automatisation
que gérard mérigots nous en rapporte et
de l' usine renault à douai
douay une expérience industrielle
l'automatisation usine pilote unique en
europe
son parti pris éliminer le plus souvent
possible les tâches pénibles dangereux
et répétitives comme c'est le cas sur
cette chaîne d'emboutissage
le but atteindre l'automatisation
intégrale pour certaines opérations
ici il est atteint l'emboutissage se
fait sans intervention humaine mise en
service la semaine dernière ce prototype
est unique au monde
l'introduction des plaques de métal
opération redoutable est résolu à
l'heure actuelle bien sûr la rentabilité
de peut être calculé l'expérience est
trop nouvelles conséquences immédiates
en tout cas deux techniciens suffisent
là où il aurait fallu six ou sept
personnes suppressions de postes peut-on
penser en fait non lusine n'existe que
depuis cinq ans et les 7000 personnes
qui travaillent représentent autant de
créations d'emplois à l'échelon régional
deuxième aspect de l'automatisation ou
de l'automation comme on voudra les
robots aspects sans aucun doute le plus
spectaculaire 9 robots ont pour tâche
ingrate et pénible de manipuler les
éléments de carrosserie et d'assurer
dans presque son intégralité
l'assemblage et la soudure de toute la
voiture d'origine américaine ces robots
font pour la première fois leur
apparition en europe
à titre d'exemple ils peuvent effectuer
un point de soudure par seconde et ce
même dans les endroits les plus
inaccessibles de la carrosserie
entièrement programmer leur mémoire
permet d'enregistrer 1024 mouvements
différents ils exécutent absolument sol
les opérations qu'ils auront été
commandé ces techniques adoptées à douai
devrait progressivement être étendu aux
autres usines renault
toutefois ce qui est possible à doué qui
est une usine nouvelle n'est pas
forcément transposable ailleurs ailleurs
cela pourrait signifier compressions de
personnel or aujourd'hui période
difficile pour l'emploi l'amélioration
des conditions de travail ne constitue
pas forcément l'objectif principal une
précision que j'apprends c'est par
intérim que pierre rentes est nommé
porte parole de l'elysée la france est
prête sous condition a participé à une
action de relance voilà ce que
pronostique lot c d e
le comité de politique économique se
réunit en ce moment à paris si la france
est d'accord c'est à une condition que
les autres pays membres de l'osce que
dieu fasse un effort important et quand
on dit cela on se tourne parce que
toujours de l'autre côté du rhin pour
prendre le pouls de l'économie allemand
nous l'avons déjà fait pour l'italie et
la grande bretagne chez le plus fort de
nos partenaires le tableau de bord
économique se lit sur trois cadrans une
faible hausse des prix trois et demi
pour cent l'année dernière des
exportations record
l'allemagne championne du monde mais
aussi un fort taux de chômage
michel meyer bonne si nous regardons nos
problèmes internes comme allemand il y a
des problèmes graves
c'est numéro un c'est le chômage depuis
presque quatre anneaux année nous avons
aux moyens un million de chômeurs et
c'est beaucoup trop pour un pays
florissant que comme l'allemagne
si moi personnellement j'aurai le choix
entre et s'impose en hausse des prix et
une diminution remarquable des chômeurs
disent on a une temi millions moi je
suis des idées pour une certaine hausse
tv sans doute dans un pays où un ouvrier
sur trois travaille déjà pour
l'exportation
les chefs d'entreprises hésitent à
investir et à créer des emplois surtout
un moment où partant de la valeur du
dutchbat les produits made in germany
sont plus chers que jamais de son côté
le gouvernement schmitt refuse
catégoriquement de relancer les affaires
en injectant de l'argent public dans les
circuits économiques l'allemagne
fédérale joue toujours la carte de la
stabilité
elle refuse fermement de jouer le rôle
de locomotive de l'économie mondiale
comme le souhaitent les américains
naturellement nous sommes très honorés
que on estime que nous
vous jouez d'une locomotive mais je
prends cette théorie est un peu fausse
la théorie d'une locomotive et la
théorie pour aider les oiseaux avec
l'augmentation de nos importations nous
avons déjà aidé beaucoup l'effet que
vous me donnez là sont connus des
experts américains
alors pourquoi est ce que
l'administration américaine persiste à
vous demander ce que nous vous ne pouvez
pas satisfaire oui pour être très fort
je craigne beaucoup l'amateurisme
actuelle avancées concernant cette
question
et parce qu'un un pont croix à cause de
notre stabilité et de surprises dans le
commerce extérieur que nous pouvons
faire beaucoup plus de choses
son calcul on les fait que je vais que
j'ai donné à vous ça veut dire
malgré les faits existants on rêve
toujours d'une grande aide
allemands et ça j'appelle à maturité la
suite de l'actualité à l'étranger
d'abord la chine voilà maintenant que
des dignitaires des églises catholique
et protestantes ont fait leur
réapparition pour la première fois
depuis 16 ans donnons déjà dit que des
délégués bouddhistes et musulmans
étaient revenus sur la scène publique
chinoise zaïre à la suite d'un coup
d'état manqué contre le président mobutu
250 officiers auraient été arrêtées ces
derniers jours c'est ce qu'a affirmé un
mouvement des d'opposer aux opposants
établie à bruxelles et à l'autre bout de
l'afrique par comparaison on est un
petit peu admiratif de ce qui s'est
passé dimanche au sénégal le président
senghor a été une nouvelle fois réélu à
la tête de l'état ça c'est presque
normal mais ce qui l'est moins en
afrique en tout cas c'est qu'il avait
contre lui
un autre candidat à la présidence
victoire sans surprise pour le président
senghor qui vote ici avec sa femme
française à 71 ans il est réélu à la
tête de l'état avec 82% des voix son
parti le parti socialiste conserve ainsi
une très confortable majorité à la
chambre
mais il devra compter cette fois avec
l'opposition dont 17 députés vont faire
leur entrée au parlement
20% des électeurs ont en effet voté pour
m wad chef du parti démocratique
sénégalais et principal adversaire du
président senghor
l'opposition communiste autorisée depuis
un an seulement à sortir de la
clandestinité n'a pas obtenu assez de
voix pour avoir un siège à l'assemblée
la compétition électorale était limité à
trois parties les exclus avaient appelé
à l'abstention mais 67% des électeurs
ont voté ces élections dépasse le simple
cadre sénégalais et serve d'exemple pour
continent africain où les régimes
autoritaires permettent rarement à la
population d'exprimer librement un choix
politique
les émeutes contre le régime somoza en
repris hier au nicaragua après une pause
de deux semaines les violents
affrontements entre manifestants et
forces de l'ordre ont fait une vingtaine
de victimes
le président se mosad dont le régime
n'est pas précisément libéral a malgré
tout l'intention de rester jusqu'à la
fin de son mandat de trois ans la guerre
civile est aux portes de la capitale du
nicaragua à 30 km exactement dans cette
ville de masaya où la population a pris
les armes contre le régime du général
somoza les premiers réfugiés affirme que
l'armée a massacré des dizaines
d'habitants pour tenter d'arrêter les
meneurs de la révolte
l'insurrection qui se généralise est la
conséquence de l'assassinât du chef de
l'opposition pedro chamorro le 10
janvier dernier
depuis cette date les émeutes et les
grèves succès pts aux manifestations
d'hostilité au régime le général somoza
dont la dynastie tient le pays depuis 43
ans bat le rappel de ses partisans et
oblige les fonctionnaires
racée multi mais par fan d'un attentat
il doit parler à la foudre derrière une
vitre à l'épreuve des balles somoza
possède dit-on 30% des terres du pays et
sa fortune personnelle est plus élevé
que le budget national
il promet des réformes en faveur des
paysans et qui quittera le pouvoir à la
fin de son mandat mais le tout puissant
général a juré aussi d' écraser par la
force de son armée toute forme
d'insurrection
à ce stade du journal deux informations
étonnantes d'abord un jugement par
contumace devant les assises de la haute
saône une condamnation à mort pour un
vol simple et un vol à main armée ainsi
le veut la loi
l'avocat général qui a requis la peine
de mort la regrettée en jugeant cette
loi absurde
une affaire qui aura peut-être des
suites il ya aussi l'histoire assez
émouvante d'un petit garçon de 7 ans qui
était parti faire des commissions dans
un magasin d'arras dans le pas de calais
c'était samedi après midi
et comme le petit daniel ne revenait pas
les policiers ont entrepris des
recherches qui ont abouti finalement à
10mo dimanche seulement vers 13 heures
le petit garçon avait passé 18 heures
enfermé dans les toilettes publiques
il portait son sac à provisions serré
contre lui il avait osé appeler
personnes c'est donc à daniel que je
vais offrir ce qui va suivre
c'est à dire un avant-goût du concert
que mikis theodorakis va donner demain
et le 3 mars à la salle pleyel à paris
écoutez c'est très beau
au lycée
ma foi fort
chef c'est lui
et vous de le
on veut aller
ils veulent
tha
composite a cédé et créer un mouvement
musical et qui est inspiré par la
tradition populaire qui est destiné au
peuple mais qui n'est pas seulement la
musique les airs le moi je fais une
distinction un remix by their la musique
populaire
la musique une musique plaisir qui nous
aide à oublier de la musique populaire
qui nous aide à ces mêmes mal à se
remémorer à la mémoire et voilà ça cela
de vue
le saxophoniste et clarinettiste de jazz
alex combelles est mort hier à nantes il
avait 65 ans il faisait partie de la
première génération des jazzmen français
aura dukes cet américain qui a conçu
pendant la guerre en 1942 le plus grand
d'hydravion du monde
il mesurait 320 pieds pouvait embarquer
700 personnes c'est seulement après la
guerre le 2 novembre 1947 qui plus d'y
coller pour l'unique et dernière fois
sur un mile seulement c'est à dire un
petit peu plus de 1 km dans le port de
langue beach faut dire que 320 pieds ça
fait à peu près la hauteur de de
l'immeuble de neuf étages
voyez ce décollage cette unique
décollage ça va pas durer longtemps
regardez bien il s'élève très peu et
déjà réplique du nez il a parcouru un
tout petit peu plus d'un kilomètre
yoox a vécu toute sa vie pour l'aviation
et même dans un hangar son hydravion je
crois marquera l'histoire de l'aviation
nous allons maintenant un nouveau
confrère tout faire dans sa maison c'est
son nom est un mensuel qui vous donnera
de multiples astuces pour votre maison
la météo maintenant pour demain mercredi
les températures resteront élevées pour
la saison le temps sera très variable
avec alternance d'éclaircies et de
nuages et de pluie parfois orageuses
le dernier journal avec gérard holtz aux
alentours de minuit je vous remercie de
nous avoir suivis bonsoir à demain tout
à l'heure vous allez retrouver chaque
laura qui avait un petit peu le trac au
début de cette émission jacques le rat
pour les émissions de la campagne
électorale office
à demain